[Music]
let's move on to some social media
questions real quick you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter
tick tock and instagram at the
minimalists it looks like we have a
question here actually this one's from
youtube just c has a question for us i'm
an extreme minimalist and i'm frustrated
that i'm paying to store a few items
while i'm in between houses for the next
three months i'd hate to sell my
favorite things but i feel like i'm
wasting my money any thoughts on storage
we tell ourselves these stories right
that conflict with one another i'm an
extreme minimalist but i also have a
storage locker just see i can tell you
this
if you are an extreme minimalist you
probably don't have a storage locker i'm
not an extreme minimalist i'm a
minimalist
but i don't see minimalism as being
extreme i see minimalism as sort of the
natural state in many ways i will say
this though so we get caught up in those
definitions i'm an extreme minimalist
i'm a type three hoarder whatever it is
right
and
you were defined by
who you are not by the things you own
right and also the same thing is true
with you're also not defined by the
things you don't own
if i own fewer things i'll be a better
person no you are you regardless of the
things you own the question is the
things that i have around me do they
augment my experience of life if so
wonderful i wouldn't encourage you to
get rid of them in fact keep your
storage locker if they augment your life
now is the perfect time to start
questioning those things though because
if you're going to use them a few months
from now why deprive yourself of those
things
like if i went to matt and got rid of
all of his studio equipment all of his
guitars i would make his life markedly
worse now it doesn't mean that you
couldn't do an experiment for a period
of time matt it might be really helpful
to say i'm taking all of your
instruments for 30 days and during those
30 days but i really miss this one i
miss this one and you come back at the
end of 30 days and you're like you know
what
i didn't miss that that or that
huh maybe the things i thought added
value to my life
don't actually add value i can let those
go
but those other things man these really
enhance my life let me let me hold on to
that yeah the idea of being an extreme
minimalist but holding on to uh
feeling badly that you have a storage
locker is sort of counterintuitive right
like the first thing you should get rid
of is feeling badly for having a storage
locker
you know and then it's like
that's the real superfluous
bit in that whole thing that's right
yeah there's sort of a conflict there
right hey i have an identity
as a minimalist and i'm doing this thing
that conflicts with my concept of the
identity help me resolve that
contradiction
you don't have to let go of the stuff
but i would say let go of the identity
be who you are if minimalist is an
accurate description of who you are and
how you live
let other people call you that and sure
when it makes sense you can refer to
yourself as that as well but don't be
attached to that label i am a minimalist
in a way that causes you to judge
yourself by having more than a certain
amount of things or by having a storage
unit the other thing i would say too is
that you know
how much you love something
when you have to pay for it and you know
how much you love it by how much you're
willing to pay for it and so i would
just you know apply what i call the
casino technique when you go to the
casino my advice is if you're going to
go in there and you're going to gamble
away your money because you think that's
fun
that's up to you but just determine your
number ahead of time what's it going to
be what's your stopping point is it 50
is it 200
how much are you willing to lose and
when are you going to stop because you
know what's going to happen when you get
in that casino you're either going to
get a hot hand and feel like you're
limitless and you're just gonna come out
of there with a million dollars or
you're gonna get in the hole and lose
something and you're gonna feel like i
gotta keep going to dig myself out of
the hole so determine your number ahead
of time and then when you get to that
number you know what to do it's the same
way with your stuff you decided to put
something in storage because it mattered
enough to you to at least put it in
there for a day if it's starting to hurt
then that means you've got something
going on within you telling yourself hey
this is valuable to me but it's not
infinitely valuable
how much more valuable is it for you to
hold on to it is it worth 100 more
dollars is it worth a thousand more
dollars determine your number and once
you get there let it go because then
it's going to cost you more than it more
than it actually benefits you if you
don't
the price of holding onto it right now
is
a lot it's high it's not just the price
of the storage locker but it's the
psychological cost the mental clutter
that it's causing the emotional the
heart clutter that you're experiencing
because you feel this incongruity i am
this type of person and yet i'm doing
this well that's we've been talking
about expectations today that's one of
the things here i've set this
expectation a extreme minimal this is
who i am as a person and therefore i
shouldn't have a storage locker okay
fine well then get rid of the storage
locker but is that really going to help
you maybe but if you're getting rid of
the things that are in the storage
locker that serve you then you might be
worse off and so sometimes it just has
to do with telling ourselves a different
story yeah yep and the idea of wiggly
what we talked about rigidity versus
wiggly it's like being rigid costs so
much
and it's like saying this is who i am
but this isn't in
in
it they're not working together and it's
like yeah because you're just let it go
like let your identity go in that way
the idea and just be right now you have
a storage locker with your stuff in it
okay
you know what i mean and then
next step
and hey look i i don't i don't address
this unempathetically oh yeah yeah i
gotta be empathetic i i just no no i'm
not contrasting with you i'm saying i
just completed a cross-country move and
i can say a considerable amount of my
things arrived broken
chipped mishandled damaged or some
things were just lost altogether and
it's incredibly frustrating but one
thing it makes me appreciate is the fact
that before i left
i got rid of about half of my stuff
and i'm thankful that i'm not
experiencing that anger and frustration
over that stuff because if i still had
that stuff i would be even more angry i
would be even more frustrated and so
the more things you have the more things
you have to worry about and sometimes
you know the fastest way to piece is to
assess the costs
take an honest look at the stress
holding on to something is causing you
and saying let it go you know just let
it go and if it's the type of thing that
makes you say but no no it really means
a lot to me well then just own the
choice that you're making
to pay for it and don't condemn yourself
don't look at it as being inconsistent
with some identity you have
i'm reminded of something jay
krishnamurti said when he's talking
about acceptance and what you're it
reminds me of what you're going through
right now he said whatever happens i
don't mind
just that alone like something is going
to happen undoubtedly something's going
to happen and you can interpret it as
good bad whatever
but whatever happens i don't mind if we
can find that place because we're not
always going to be there we're going to
mind we're going to get pissed off we're
going to get angry we're going to get
frustrated we're going to get upset but
realizing
that it's also possible to react
differently it's possible to not mind
because something happens to me and matt
doesn't know about it he doesn't mind
yeah because he doesn't even know about
it yeah and even if he does know about
it he's not going to mind the same way
that i mined
and so it is possible for me to not mind
or at least to mind it a lot less yeah
than i do right now that was what tk was
saying about play it's about play yeah
like
we're really
we don't play enough we see things as
sort of these life or death
things and it's like if you see it as a
game and you see it as kind of play
then sometimes you sometimes you make
shots sometimes you don't sometimes
things work the way you think they
should sometimes they don't and you can
learn from them and sometimes you know
it's the key should i go home and take
my damaged furniture and just play just
like take a baseball bat crack and happy
like look at that i did a better job at
ruining it than the movers
that sounds terrible by the way
[Music]
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free